SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
My name is Saad Ali.
I am an engineer on
Google Kubernetes Engine,
and I'm joined here
by Aparna Sinha.
She is the group
program manager--
product manager for all of
Kubernetes and our Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Pleasure to have you, Aparna.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you, Saad.
Pleasure to be here.
SAAD ALI: So you have
been deeply involved
with the strategy for GKE and
defining the product vision.
What do you think
sets the offering
that GKE has today in terms of
what customers are asking for?
APARNA SINHA: Yeah.
Sure, yeah.
I've been with the project
for the last 3 and 1/2 years.
So really seeing
it grow from a baby
until I would say much
broader enterprise
adoption both in the open
source as well as, of course,
on our cloud with GKE and really
have been with the GKE service
from the beginnings
as well as we
worked through first
introducing it as a service
and building all of these
enterprise grade features
into it for
enterprise readiness,
making sure upgrades are much
more automated and low impact
for the customers, and
moving into the future,
providing GKE On-Prem.
So what I've heard from
customers and users,
both open source
users and customers,
is that they want
to be able to use
GKE in their own on-prem
environment, which is why we're
introducing GKE On-Prem and why
we introduced it at GCP Next
and, we're moving
forward with that.
And they want to have Google's
expertise from having managed
it in production as a service
for the last 3 and 1/2 years
as well as the
expertise that comes
from being directly involved
deeply with the open source
projects.
So you probably
saw in my keynote,
I showed the distribution
of contributions
to Kubernetes open
source over the last year
based on the CNCS statistics.
Google is contributing
40-plus percent of that.
And so what that means is that
we're very current with all
of the issues with Kubernetes.
We're building solutions.
And so when you
partner with Google,
you have that partnership
with the core maintainers.
And so, for example,
on GKE, we're
always ahead in knowing
what's coming up for our users
both in the open source
and on the cloud.
With the security
vulnerabilities
that are happening, we're always
patching them ahead of time
and then bringing them
into GKE, making sure
that the most secure
version is there.
Same thing with the versions and
upgrades finding the problems
and making sure
that the customers
don't have to worry about it.
So that's the second piece.
Customers love
Kubernetes I would
say for all of the feature
functionality, the resiliency,
the productivity, the
higher utilization
that you get when you run your
applications on Kubernetes.
But they also don't always want
to manage Kubernetes and have
to keep up with all of the
capabilities and program
all of the capabilities.
So we try and provide a much
more managed distribution.
We'll be providing it on prem.
We've been providing it in
the cloud for several years,
not only managing your masters--
obviously managing the sizing
and the backup of your FCD
and scaling of the masters--
but also managing much
more of your cluster
itself with node
upgrades and node auto
repair and node auto scaling.
These are some of the
features that over time we've
brought in to make sure that
customers can worry less
about the infrastructure.
And then I think I talked
about in my keynote today.
We're building
also up the stack,
providing now node
auto provisioning.
So you can be hands free.
You don't have to worry as much
about is the cluster running.
You can focus on what do you
want to run in the cluster.
And so we've actually just
this week in fact earlier today
announced that Istio on
GKE is moving to beta,
and it's available for
existing clusters as well
as new clusters.
And we're going to be providing
it with a single click
install, which I
demoed in the keynote
and also providing basic
lifecycle operations so
upgrading SGO.
So it's really a lot
easier to use Istio.
You don't have to know a lot
of the guts of it yourself.
But you can get the
benefit of being
able to monitor and view and
discover all of your services
across your clusters
and then also be
able to set security policies,
ensure encrypted traffic
and authentication
and then also be
able to use the basic
functionalities of a proxy
like for load balancing
obviously and also for traffic
control.
So those are the
capabilities you
get for not entirely for free
but much more easily in GKE.
And then lastly is bringing
that developer experience
with Knative and
the GKE serverless
add on, which is still
an alpha, but that
is also something customers
have been looking for.
They love Kubernetes,
but then they
want to give their developers
a hands free experience where
they can just go use all
of the functionality,
write their code,
focus on their code,
and not have to worry
about all the rest,
not have to worry about
setting up ingress,
exposing their services
and how to expose the services,
not have to worry about how
to auto scale.
And those are the things
that Knative does really well
under the covers.
So I would say those
are the three things
that customers been asking for.
Give me something in
my own environment,
give me something that I
don't have to manage a lot of,
and give me a good developer
experience for my developers.
SAAD ALI: So is it fair to
summarize it as with GKE, we've
built this massive open source
ecosystem with Kubernetes,
Istio, Knative, and we've now
made it very, very dead simple
to use on the cloud
side and we're
bringing that simplicity
over to people's data centers
and completing the
story, and is that
what customers are asking for?
APARNA SINHA: Yeah, well, so I
think the ecosystem is actually
one of the best parts of
working on this project,
and one of the best parts of
working with an open source
community.
The way that the
project is architected,
it's very much
amenable to extensions.
And you know that.
You've been working on
CSI, which just moved to GA
and 1.13, so congratulations.
We got a lot of such interfaces.
And what that does is it
really opens the project up
to an ecosystem, a very
rich ecosystem that
can build and not just build
but also customize Kubernetes
for specific
environments, customize it
for the on-prem
environment that has
a particular type of storage or
particular type of networking
preference or particular
type of security preference.
So all of those
things are plugable.
And from a business
perspective, what it means
is that we can bring that
ecosystem into our cloud.
So Kubernetes, I
tried to think of it--
I like to think of it and call
it a Kubernetes First Cloud.
Google is a Kubernetes
first cloud.
It is because GKE is one of
the most popular services
on our cloud.
The vast majority
of our customers
use GKE in some form or another.
Everyone from "New York
Times," Paypal, eBay,
these are some of the--
and every major retailer,
that's fresh in our minds
because we just went through
Black Friday, Cyber Monday,
and we scaled all these
retailers to new heights
in terms of their business,
all with zero outages.
So very, very proud of that.
Really coming to maturity.
So Google is really a
Kubernetes First Cloud.
We think about well how
can Kubernetes run well?
What kind of networking
features can we
build like network
end point groups
as an example, IP
aliases as an example.
What can we do to make
the experience better
for Kubernetes users
on Google Cloud.
And when you have the
Kubernetes First Cloud,
I think it makes sense
as an ecosystem provider
to really come in and provide
your offering on Google Cloud.
And so that's what we've
done with the Kubernetes
marketplace.
But then the rich thing
here, the really rich aspect
is that we're providing that GKE
experience now in your own data
center on prem.
So that same ecosystem that's in
the Kubernetes marketplace now
carries over and
now has much broader
reach even beyond
Google Cloud to on prem.
SAAD ALI: That sounds awesome.
Let's switch gears a little
bit and talk about KubeCon.
You have been to
quite a few KubeCons.
How does this feel
different from others
that you've been to?
APARNA SINHA: I love KubeCon.
KubeCon has a real
special place in my heart.
And this is my fifth
or sixth KubeCon.
And I've been comparing
and contrasting.
Seattle is of course a
very special location.
We have a big
presence in Seattle.
A lot of my team-- a lot of the
Kubernetes team is based here.
And I've been here--
I think this is the
second or third time
that we've been in Seattle.
And this is the obviously
the largest KubeCon
that we've had with
8,000 or 9,000 attendees.
SAAD ALI: 8,000, right.
APARNA SINHA: And
this is the first time
we've been in this huge venue.
I think it's been
very well done.
It seems very approachable.
A lot of people,
a lot of familiar
faces, the whole
community is here.
So it's really great
to meet everyone.
Yeah.
It's a real tradition.
And I think in particular
the Google team
is out here in full force.
I think they got
more than 300 people.
SAAD ALI: Absolutely.
What are you
looking most forward
to this week in terms of
activities going on at KubeCon?
APARNA SINHA: Well, I'm really
looking forward to the keynotes
by Brian Grant and Tim
Hockin and Clayton.
SAAD ALI: The stories
of the old days.
APARNA SINHA: Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know what
the content will be,
but that is something that
I'm really looking forward to.
And then the Sig meet ups tend
to be-- the Sig meetings tend
to be very popular as well.
There's a diversity
luncheon I believe,
if it hasn't already passed,
so I'm looking forward to that.
And then just
catching up with all
of the familiar faces in the
community and meeting folks
from other companies, especially
all of these companies
on security and networking,
the whole ecosystem that
has sprung up, I
always really enjoy
meeting them and
hearing from them.
And then, of course,
there are a lot of users.
There are a lot of users
and customers here,
so that's always the best part.
SAAD ALI: And to
wrap it up, put you
on the spot, what's your
favorite KubeCon memory?
APARNA SINHA: Oh, well, I
don't know if it's my-- yeah,
I guess it is my favorite.
So two years ago in 2016
when we came to Seattle,
that was on November 7th
I think or November 6th,
and it was election day.
And the KubeCon after
party on November 6th,
we were all in this
like wonderful venue,
all kinds of candles
and beautiful lights
and great snacks and everybody
was watching the election
and everybody was expecting
it to go a certain way
and it went a different way.
And then the morning
after just being
with-- it's kind of like being
with your family a little bit,
but it's a much more
extended family.
And I felt like it was nice
being with the cloud native
community.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, I was
talking to Tim earlier today,
and he says even
though this is scaled
to the scale of 8,000 people, it
still feels like a big family.
And I think that's
the beauty of KubeCon.
So thank you very much
for your time, Aparna.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you.
SAAD ALI: We're
going to hand it off.
APARNA SINHA: Yeah,
great talking to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]